praised by critics as an historian who
has the literary talents of the novelist
John Lucas is the author of more than 20
books including the Hitler of history in
which he explores German Chancellor
Adolf Hitler's life by examining more
than 100 biographies that have been
written about him the recipient of the
Ingersoll Prize other books include the
great powers in Eastern Europe history
of the Cold War outgrowing democracy and
historical interpretation of the u.s. in
the 20th century the dual Hitler vs.
Churchill the 10th of May to the 31st of
August 1940 and one of my very favorites
5 days in May an account of the
transformation of the attitude of the
British cabinet in the face of his most
recent books democracy and populism was
published by a Yale University Press
as his new book June 1941 a story which
will be a few moments ago in my office
professor Lucas served from 1947 to 1994
as professor of history at Chestnut Hill
College and as its department chair from
1947 to 74 he's also had visiting
appointments at many universities
including Columbia Princeton Johns
Hopkins and the University of Budapest
in his native Hungary
I learned this morning that this
afternoon that on his arrival to the US
in 1946 though one of his first
engagements was to come and give a talk
at Yale at the at the tender age of 23
so we're delighted to have you here for
this return visit the title professor
Lucas is chosen for his lecture is
popular tides and the ship of state and
I'm pleased to introduce to you John
Lucas
Thank You mr. Shapiro ladies and
gentlemen since I'm honored to give this
lecture and as you believe me that this
is not an empty phrase or an expression
of false modesty pray allow me to
introduce myself by which I mean not my
so-called achievements but perhaps the
main character of my thinking and this
is this is that contrary to old dominant
views of versions of materialism and
determinism this is that the most
important indeed the most dominant
default the man most important indeed
the fundamental basis of history is what
people think and what they believe and
then and that the entire material
organization of the world is the
superstructure of that now at the same
time my auntie materialism is also
contrary to that of most idealist
philosophers because it is my conviction
also that ideas as such do not matter
what matters is why and when and how
people choose them we do not have ideas
less gentlemen we choose them and today
my discourse attempts to describe two
examples of this condition in the
history of United States more than 150
years ago more than 170 years ago our
great master and seer Tocqueville
soand describe something about which he
drew a conclusion which is largely
ignored by thinkers and historians and
political theorists since this was that
the movement of ideas and what may be
called public opinion in the democratic
age and in a Democratic Society it's not
at all rapid but often agonizingly slow
now at the stand talk we lived and wrote
those people who feel the coming of
democracy had thought and believed the
opposite they believed that when masses
of people come to power the unavoidable
result would be a feverish agitation of
ideas of going from one extreme to the
other
shaking society apart with incalculable
damages to safety and order doctor wrote
that the very contrary was true the very
factor of public opinion its manufacture
and displeasure lence the manufacture
and the prevalence of public opinion
would result in a faithful and often
lamentable and sometimes even dangerous
slowness amounting to lassitude an
obstacle to change when necessary now he
did not particularly relate this to
foreign policy in the democratic age
about even though in other his brilliant
chapters he said that the conduct of
foreign policy will be much more
difficult in a democratic age than in
aristocratic societies when minorities
ruled and now it is now there are two
examples in the foreign policy of the
United States or in other words to the
to to it to the determination of the
course of the giant ship of state that I
must turn I will turn the first example
will focus
on the 1930s when the first symptoms of
a coming Second World War began to
accumulate my second example we focused
on the early mid fifties when the first
symptoms of a change in the nature of
the Cold War was beginning to occur the
United States declared war on Germany in
April 1917 there's reason to believe
that the division in Congress at the
declaration rather accurately reflected
the divisions of public opinion at the
time 363 congressman voted for the war
50 against 90 senators voted for the war
6 against very soon after this
declaration of war the emotional tide of
hatred against Germany reached absurd
Peaks which I need not illustrate at
this point let me just tell you two
things from 1917 onwards for three years
the Metropolitan Opera struck Wagner
from his repertoire and in 1918 the
judgest of the Westminster Kennel Club
decided to exclude X homes from the list
of approved species yes now two years
later this tide receded reaction and
disappointment set in not so much
against the war as against the results
of the war not so much against Germany
as against Europe at large the Senate
rejected President Wilson's favorite
idea American participation League of
Nations thereafter the majority of
Americans rejected the Democrats and
chosen Republican Party President
Harding won easily he coined a new word
normalcy this was a triumph of American
halation ISM which is an overall term
that is imprecise and the components of
which were complicated but a diagnosis
and analysis of this is not my main
purpose now what I wish to emphasize
what I wish to draw attention to that
the peak of the popular tide of
isolation isolationism occurred not in
1920 but 16 or 17 years later in 1936
and 1937 now this reversal of the
National enthusiasm for World War one in
1917 involved isolationism as well as
the image of Germany these two matters
were not the same but they overlapped
nonetheless let me not race very briefly
but I hope not superficially the
development or call it the stages of
this huge tide of slowly rising American
opinion and sentiment it began what we
may call historical revisionism contrary
to the so called scientific and the so
called object Objectivist conception of
historians don't worry about that
because history is revisionist history
consists history consists of the forever
rethinking of positions and people of
the past which then made this rethinking
then maybe the result of new evidences
but also new perspectives see unlike law
the historian history deals with
multiple jeopardy now what happened
beginning in 1921 was that American
intellectuals journalists historians
with the help of the then newly opened
and published
German documents began to question
openly the wartime slogan of the wartime
slogan of the unique German war guilt
there were by and large some reasons for
this kind of questioning but it's
significant that the propagators of this
questioning were by and large men and
people who have turned against the
extreme manifestations of American
militarism during the war most of them
who will designate liberals and radicals
thus for example as early as 1920 the
journal donation attacked friends and
not German militarism a year later in
editorial in the same periodical wrote
who has contributed more to the myth of
a guilty nation plotting the war against
a peaceful Europe than the so called
historians who occupy distinguished
chairs in our universities now at that
time 1921 such opinions affected only a
small segment of what may be called
public opinion they were current only
among some historians and intellectuals
yet in no country other than the United
States were the successive waves of
revisionism so influential in eventually
moulding public opinion and even
national politics at large before the
end of the 1920s the revisionist cause
became supported not only by many
historians but by celebrated literary
figures such as Menken or Albert Locke
and by the editors for some of the most
prominent literary weekly and monthly
magazines then in 1930 around 1930 the
revisionist wave was further swelled by
the confluence of another historical
argument that about the origins of the
war
in 1914 not about the origins of the war
1914 but about the American entry into
the war in 1917 the time had come to
revise not only the thesis of the German
war guilt but the story of American
involvement of the war by the early
1930s article after article book after
book attacked American intervention
first world war this new kind of
retrospective American pacifism was no
longer the main argument of isolationist
Republicans it was taken up by many
Democrats as well
gradually simply what were earlier the
beliefs and arguments of a few
intellectuals and historians these
arguments were trickling down to the
first of the political and then to the
popular level its momentum was gaining
ground by 1930 the writings of the
revisionist had a definite influence on
important congressmen and Senators
mostly Western populist such as George
Norris Gerald f9 William E Bora who had
once opposed the First World War but by
1934 the isolationist and revisionist M
pacifist sentiments had merged their
potential popularity was so large that a
congressional committee presided by
senator 9 founded politic to raise a
public spectacle to investigate the
doings the mischiefs of bankers and
munition makers and other villainous
promoters of the American entry into the
war seventeen years before you may be
interested to know that one of the
counsels of the night committee was
Alger Hiss a Quaker pacifist then not
yet a communist in 1935 Congress passed
the first Neutrality Act
a definite reaction against the memories
of the First World War in 1936 and 37 an
amendment to the very Constitution of
the United States was proposed in
Congress by Congressman Ludlow requiring
that any American declaration of war
must be preceded by a national
referendum and then and depend upon the
results of that in 1937 the Neutrality
Act was extended and made more stringent
by that year did this new version of
World War one and the rejection of all
wars had appeared in high school
textbooks a Senator Homer bone of
Washington declared a quote
effect known even to schoolchildren in
this country everyone now knows to know
has to come to recognize that the Great
War was utter social insanity and we had
no business in it at all
this was 1937 now I have not tried to
illustrate a significant phenomenon to
which alas few historians have devoted
sufficient attention this is the
slowness of the momentum with which
ideas move and then appear on the
surface or call it the time lag in the
movement of ideas which then appear on
the political surface at the wrong time
that alone gives the light to Victor
Hugo's famous saw about an idea whose
time has come
believe me I'm not a cynic when I say
that I think an idea whose time has come
cannot be any good or seldom any good
now the high tide of revisionism or call
it isolationism or call it American
exceptionalism came not in the early
twenties when there may have been cogent
reasons to mitigate the mistreatment of
Germany
it occurred in the mid 30s when German
was rising in you and how here is one
instructive example of what was
happening the most serious is still very
valuable book about the history of
American intervention the First World
War was written by serious member name
of water Millis
it's called his the road to war was
published in 1935 it became a
best-seller with 60,000 copies in print
in 1936 but millets was a serious and
honest man who regretted this he was
applauded by the youth some people were
making of his book that after all dealt
with the past and not with the then
present by 1938 Millis was for
resistance indeed intervention against
Hitler and other dictators he wrote an
article 1939 is not 1914 but I'm running
ahead of my story where I must focus on
1936 under 37 and when the history not
only the history of books but what had
become the high-tide as full of ISIL
spread now over the broad lowlands of
popular sentiment there are umpteen
evidences for this public opinion
research was begun by George Gallup in
1935 in 1937 he reported that seventy
percent of Americans were opposed to any
kind of American intervention in any
European war yet this was the year 1937
when Hitler Mussolini and the Japanese
were not only rising but starting to
move in October 1937 President Roosevelt
made a speech in Chicago that expressed
his concerns with the world a speech
that in retrospect reflected his wish to
change the course of the American civil
state that was the so called quarantine
speech in which this president obliquely
not specifically and in very general too
said something about an American and
international necessity to quarantine
all aggressors the reaction to the
speech of Roosevelt was divided in the
papers it was not overwhelming the
critical but this president found it
politically think so during the next two
years when Hitler was overrun in Europe
when Mussolini thought it best to ally
with him when the Japanese were over
running the entire coast of China
Roosevelt's moose in foreign policy were
undertaking mostly secretly while his
public statements were couched in
generalities he was convinced even well
into the second world war that many if
not most of the American people were
isolationist and must be talked to as
such a few year a few days before his
third term election in October 1940 in
Boston he said I say to you again and
again and again your boys are not going
to be sent into any Foreign Wars then of
course was not what Roosevelt thought
and believed but my theme today is not
Roosevelt's character or his foreign
policy I am not even going to speculate
whether an open him whether an open
American Declaration let alone
involvement in Europe or in China before
1940 would have really deterred Hitler
or the Japanese Empire in a march
forward it may be enough to state that
the height and the mass of the popular
and populous tide in 1937 was a
tremendous handicap or obstacle for any
American leader who scanning the
horizons of the world would have seen
the need to change the course of the
American ship of state
I'll turn to the second example of my
discourse that is similar but not
identical with the earlier sketched
example in our national history as a
matter of fact it is only similar in the
essential factor of the time lag or
momentum the American political and
popular reaction against the second
world war 2 was similar but not
identical was that against you first it
was more subdued it was seldom outspoken
and its components differed from those
of 2 or 20 years before it was similar
in that it led to rise of the Republican
Party until the decline of the Democrats
the slogan of the Republicans in the
1946 congressional election in which
they gained much was suggestive and
implicit had enough enough of liberalism
enough of New Deal enough of alliances
to the Soviet Union communistic
influencing the government so forth and
so forth two years later President
Truman was still able to eke out a
narrow victory but meanwhile a change
had occurred that in a way would
dominate American politics for the next
40 years or even more this was the rise
of anti-communism that very soon
threatened to became identical because
in the minds of millions of Americans it
was identical with American patriotism
but before sketching it's phenomenal
rise let me draw attention to revolution
in popular sentiment from 1945 to 1947
because it may tell us something about
the inadequate term of isolationism what
happened by 1947 was that most
isolationist who only a few years before
were determined to oppose bitter
any kind of American intervention
against Germany now had become the most
insisted proponents of American
intervention against Russia this again
is not the place to analyze and diagnose
the source of this conversion if indeed
conversion it was since the theme of my
discourse is not that of the sources but
of the consequences of what was
happening there after the popular and
political tide for of anti-communism
rose and rose reaching unprecedented
heights in 1954-55 and receding only
slowly and partially thereafter of
course events in the world in the late
forties the soviet enforcement of
totally subservient communist
governments in Eastern Europe the Berlin
Blockade the Korean War so forth and so
forth contributed to it and it also
brought about largely reasonable
adjustments in the course of the
American ship of state such as President
Truman's decision to stand by the Greeks
and the Turks the Marshall Plan NATO and
the president decision to enter the
Korean War but note that all of these
decisions were made and undertaken
before and in 1950 while the popular
tide and obsession with communism rose
and rose ever higher during the years
thereafter again this is not the place
at the time to illustrate it's absurd
and dangerous peaks during the early
1950s but one precise example coinciding
with the huge rise and it's peaking from
1950 to 1954 the highest point is the
story of the career of Senator Joseph
McCarthy who chose to select at the
communism for his main political weapon
and instrument
only in late 1950 and whose phenomenal
rise of influence did not break until
late in the summer of 1954 President
Eisenhower himself on easily and
surreptitiously chose to arrange some
forces against McCarthy who then became
entangled in his own rope and what a
coarse and rough rope that was but now
consider that only two years earlier the
same Eisenhower had found it politic to
visit Wisconsin and endorse McCarthy who
had attacked general Marshall the
benefactor of Eisenhower as a traitor
that the very Under Secretary of War
Stevens in 1954 quailed and crumbled
before McCarthy when the latter attacked
him in 1954 that the Democrats too were
loath to say anything bad about
anti-communism indeed it was deliberate
Hubert Humphrey who in 1954 proposed
simply the outlawing outlawing the
already largely extent Communist Party
in the United States but now please pay
attention to the dent course of events
all of this enormous tide rose and rose
to its peak at the very time when the
Soviet Union had begun to retreat in
March 1952 Stalin himself proposed a
retreat of the Soviets from East Germany
in exchange for an American retreat from
the occupation of West Germany that
proposal was rejected and ignored by the
West the United States and West German
governments perhaps because it was too
dangerous but less than 12 months after
Stalin himself died there were
many signs that the new rulers in the
Soviet Union were in disarray and then
in 1954 and 55 they deceit they decided
to retreat from their occupation of
Eastern Austria they agreed to an
Austrian peace treaty they removed a
naval and military bases from Finland
they renounced their rights in Manchuria
and gave up their naval and military
bases in China they reestablished their
normal relationship with Yugoslavia they
gave diplomatic and state recognition to
West Germany without demanding that West
German its allies recognized East German
in some the retreat of the Soviet Union
from places in Eastern Europe which was
a veritable unilateral change in the
course of the Cold War occurred at the
very same time when popular sentiment in
the United States had risen to its very
peaks suffused or perhaps gorged by the
popular belief that communism and
democracy east or west were
irreconcilable that there was an
unavoidable and protracted war between
them going to the very end
I have not suggested rather than drawn a
similarity between the lamentable nature
of tides of popular sentiment around
1937 and those of less than two decades
later but they're the parallel ends in
1937 and thereafter the presence of
isolationist sentiments was an obstacle
to a president and to others who wish to
change the course of the American ship
of state in 1952 and thereafter the den
president and his Secretary of State did
not wish or even consider the necessity
of changing the course of the ship of
state
they were navigating in a chord with
popular sentiment and with a political
calculation
they're off I have a small quote from
the Diary of an important American in
ninth on the written on the two days
after Stalin died he said Stalin
successor have been appointed as was
generally expected this is a day which
the Russian advisors have looked forward
for years
Kenan and Bolin have been talking about
the day when Stalin would die but the
boys in the State Department and filling
the White House have no strategy this
could be a moment when it would be
possible to pry open the door for peace
somewhat even with some segments of the
Soviet Union but as far as we know or
can see there are no such plans
whatsoever well and you see now I wish
to draw attention to three examples what
I consider missed opportunities after
death of Stalin of the then at least
possible winding down of the some of the
Cold War and of the ideological
obtuseness that compromised the course
of the American ship of state the first
illustration and it is an illustration
of time lag instead of two men Winston
Churchill and George Kennan in different
ways and in different circumstances they
had been concerned with Stalin's and the
Soviet Union's ambitions much earlier
than were others even during the war
they had issued warnings about that to
the and then American political and
military establishment but largely in
vain they were unheard and unless until
for a long time then their voices were
heard and approved in 1946 and 1947 with
churches irons curtain speech and then
cannons long telegram and containment
proposition but as early as 1950
and even more in 1952 and 53 in
different ways and to different
audiences both Churchill and Kenan
believed that the time had come to
explore contacts with Russia for the
sake of correcting the unnatural and
dangerous division of Europe their
statements fell into a void they were
not listened to they were dismissed
sometimes with contempt the same
Eisenhower who in 1945 preferred to
embrace marshal Zhukov rather than agree
with Winston Churchill seven or eight
years later rudely dismissed Churchill
called him privately as say Nile the
same Kenan whose rejection of communism
was based on his own sterling principles
had been based on his own sterling
principles years before the Cold War was
dismissed by John Foster Dulles in 1953
and quit his long earnest position in
the American Foreign Service in one
sense both of them were like Edmund
Burke about whom George James Fox once
said Burke is a wise man but he's a wise
man too soon in other sense we may say
that both Church and Kenan were not
proponents of ideology but men and
statesmen of principle this brings me to
another argument which I confess is a
historical argument rather than an
illustration this is what to my mind is
that inevitable and overdue glance at
the entire historical landscape of the
20th century that century was a short
century lasting 75 years from 1914 to
1989 its landscape was dominated for
American American
alike by the two enormous mountain
ranges of the two world wars in the
shadows of which we were living surely
till 1989 the Second World War was
largely the consequence of the first
world war and the subsequent Cold War
was largely the consequence of the
second world war this is so obvious at
least for me there is hardly worth
restating or repeating but now consider
how this perspective is entirely
contrary to both popular and political
perspective
indeed beliefs that has governed
American politics in the course of the
American ship of state for at least 40
years from the mid forties to the last
late eighties from the end of the Second
World War to the end of the Cold War
this is the view that not only the
history of the United States but that
the entire history of the world in the
20th century was governed by the
struggle between communism and democracy
or call it communism and capitalism or
call it totalitarianism against freedom
what a very well William Buckley and
James Burnham the founders of American
conservatism so-called conservatism in
1955 put it in this way that in 1917
history changed gears whatever that
hobbling metaphor may mean you know this
is complete nonsense
you know the tragedy the catastrophe of
Europe and a 20th century was 1914 the
outbreak of the war not 1917 it also
reduces among other things the Second
World War to an odd and unnatural
episode yet nonsense or not this
perspective and belief was popular
enough to be adopted
not only by eisenhower
dollars but continuing to be the
mainstream of the popular tide that true
began to recede after receipt after 1954
but only somewhat indeed remaining
powerful enough decades later when it
helped to propel Ronald Reagan into the
presidency who then declared the Soviet
Union to be the evil empire I do not
wish to be misunderstood I did not in
the 1950s and I do not now consider the
Soviet Union as having become a
thoroughly reformed or peaceful power in
the world I do think that there was a
chance not to eliminate but to reduce
the Cold War and to attempt a correction
of the division of Europe with the new
Soviet leaders in the 1950s a
possibility do not a certainty at the
same time indeed in the same breath I
must close this the main portion of my
lecture by an illustration of how much
shortsightedness or harm the
overwhelming adoption of a popular
ideology can do to the course of the
ship of state now notice this in 1956
after Nikita Khrushchev himself accused
al him publicly and corrected Stalinism
to the leading people of Soviet Union
itself a few months later section 9 of
the republican party platform before the
1956 election called i quote for the
establishment of american naval and air
bases all around the world unquote and
this was the political party still
called isolationist by some of his
short-sighted liberal critics all around
the world
umino will ask me what is the lesson of
all this or how is all of this relevant
to American foreign policy at present my
answer is this is not relevant at all we
live in a different world and not only
because the dangers of a German Third
Reich or of an aggressive Soviet Union
are gone and the question that I wish to
raise at the end of my discourse
involves not the course of the ship of
state but the very character of the
function of his government or in other
words not so much the direction of
events but their very structure not what
happens what what makes things happen 50
years after the founding father the
elections 50 years after the founding of
the Republic and did und dying out of
the founders in the age of Jackson
elections and politics in the United
States became contests in popularity
that has been remarked by many
historians but their barn Lords have
failed to remark that there has been
another devolution not in the 19th but
in the 20th century leading no longer to
contest in popularity but of contests in
publicity now what does this have to do
with the subjects of my discourse not
very much except that we may see here to
a devolution we have seen that in 1937
the great majority of American popular
sentiment was was what was what was then
and what may still be called rather
inaccurately isolationist yet I have
also said that the reaction of public
opinion two Roosevelts quarantine speech
was divided this means that the upper
classes the it means that at that time
public opinion the opinion of educated
Americans of the middle and upper
classes or the readers of the better
city newspapers was by and large less
isolationist then was again by and large
popular sentiment
however fifteen years later in 1952 such
a distinction no longer exists the
foreign policy indeed the ideology of
the Eisenhower administration chose to
be imperfect to be in perfect or near
perfect accord with what was at that
time popular sentiment there were of
course times as during the Vietnam War
when sentiments and opinions among the
American people were divided though less
than what appeared there on the surface
but now well after the twentieth century
it makes no longer sense to distinguish
between public opinion and popular
sentiment when it comes to American
politics including that of foreign
policy all of this is but part and
parcel of a much larger and deeper
process which is the devolution of
democracy into populism so far the
Republican Party goes it's bonds
opposition to populism has devolved to a
stage where it has not only embraced
populism but where it is the principal
populist and Nationalist Party in the
United States so far as the Democratic
Party goes it is both compromised and
marked by the fear that it might not
sound nationalist or popular enough all
of this may change so let me conclude by
discourse with one somber
and one hopeful conclusion so far as the
course of the American ship of state
goes let me sighed the profound words of
the German physicist Werner Heisenberg
about the let me say utterly
questionable idea of progress in general
he wrote more than 50 years ago in 1955
there is the belief that the expansion
of material and intellectual powers of
mankind is always progress this has it's
at first not always visible limits
perhaps one can illustrate this with a
simile with the seemingly limitless
extension of its material powers mankind
seems to be in the situation of a
captain whose great ship is so strongly
built of steel and iron that his
magnetic compass indicates the ferrous
mass of the vessel but not the position
of the magnetic north such a ship cannot
reach its goal it will sail around in
circles and eventually become a subject
of the winds and the tides the danger
exists danger exists as long as the
captain fails to realize that his
compass no longer reacts to the magnetic
forces of the earth I dare to think that
mutatis mutandis this simile may apply
to the recent foreign policy of the
United States or to the main course of
the American ship of state but I shall
not conclude my discourse on a note of
black pessimism
let me net now in my audience listen to
three kinds of encouragement from three
very various sources
perhaps in descending order of their
importance one is my belief no mic
fiction and my experience my belief in
Providence that history is and remains
unpredictable the other is the maxim of
the great French moralist LaRoche
Foucault to the effect the thinks are
never as bad or as good as they seem and
the last is a statement of Edmund Burke
to whom I referred earlier who said more
than 200 years ago the people sir must
never be regarded as incurable and
responded to many of the questions the
people writing on the backs of their
notes while you were speaking but I'm
hoping you will agree nonetheless
entertain some questions but before we
start that let me just say at the
conclusion of there will be a reception
on the second
sister people sir must never be regarded
as incurable that's the only thing that
matters in the world what people think
of what they believe now the Marxists
think that think the idea so world
people think and believe art intellect
is the superstructure that the basis of
history of the world is the material
organization of it that's what some
capital is believed to both of them are
utterly wrong is just about the other
way around
a little louder we want
what's a very large question I was a
little tough on Eisenhower in this
lecture I'm usually not quite as tough
on him but I I've written about this
here and there I take exception to the
view that all the troubles silho you
know youth revolution sexual revolution
and so forth and they were troubles you
know started in the nineteen sixties and
compared to them the Eisenhower years
were benevolent and wonderful years of
peace and prosperity and moderation
this is not so I could give you many
examples exactly the example I gave here
it was in foreign policy again I must
tell you it was not ruinous it didn't
lead us in the war so but what you see a
revolution began in the nineteen fifties
to say you see it was in the nineteen
fifties that the fatal decline of the
appeal of liberal opinions and beliefs
began which is yet sinking sinking
sinking let me give you example in 1950
you know you got me on something that
you know in 1950 Lionel trilling you
know who was not a fool he said there's
no other idea in American intellectual
life with a liberal idea in 1954 a
historian Lois hearts wrote a book
published by harm or death the American
political idea is deliberate idea it was
in the same year that Bill Buckley
started his National Review on a
shoestring 30 years later the
circulation of the National Review is
larger than of the nation and the New
Republic together 30 years later more
Americans regard themselves
conservatives and liberals I also want
to tell you that the two American cities
where the country where most people
regard himself are conservative are
Houston and Dallas which is also which
are also two cities where you have the
largest percentage of divorces I mean so
far as you see in 1950 there was not a
single American political figure who
would dare to say I'm a conservative
Senator Robert Taft who was a right wing
of the Republican Party said I'm an
old-fashioned liberal McCarthy never
used the word conservative by 1960
President Eisenhower who knew how to
trim his sails said you know in many
ways I am a conservative this what this
is a revolution this is a landslide in
American history you know which still
has not been adequately analyzed
discussed described by historians
little loudly oh well you see this the
water lashline 53r that the significance
of this is only considerable in
retrospect in retrospect because you
know in Persia Iran the Middle East and
so forth you know this was a at that
time a rather exceptional event and I
would go so far that I would not
criticize the American underhanded
intervention in Persia I'm very
old-fashioned I prefer the word Persia
to Iran you know in 1953 I would you
know I I think this by and large is
probably the right thing to do and it in
the long run it did not change American
relations to the Middle East
perhaps there is again I don't know
perhaps there might be more grounds to
criticism about the American
intervention Guatemala in 1954 but they
were very lengthy petty things you see
well I'm concerned with is the American
reaction to the Soviet Union division of
Europe where as I said some adjustments
probably could have been undertaken yes
well if you look at the very long run
you know in a way what happened to the
so-called American conservatives you
know you know Bill Buckley you know who
is truly I know very well a charming man
and you know he's starting a shoestring
and gradually you see conservatism of
one kind or another and you see I'm so
well I don't talk myself I no longer
consider myself conservative I am just a
reactionary you say about that yeah but
you see this is an L this is what
happened again because of a vacuum
because of the general often warranted
and perhaps sometimes not unwarranted
disillusionment with liberalism and with
some extreme applications of liberal
ideas see there again is a time like
look look Buckley and concerns 1955 in
1964 Goldwater the first candidate who
calls himself conservative is still
creamed in the elections by 1988 II
Ronald Reagan wins the election in a new
landslide
yes yes yes I hear that question over
and over again and it's a very
intelligent question but you must have
stand the situation was quite different
we had a conference about this 12 years
ago
in a university you know I thought I was
only one of participants and almost
everybody agreed there's a wrong time
here this is no I mean the war between
your analysis in Germany in December
1940 was was inevitable the United
States was already engaged in a virtual
naval war with German in the Atlantic so
the very fact that Germany declared the
declaration or rather pronouncement of
war came from Berlin and not Washington
given the atmospheric condition of the
time was almost irrelevant
yes well that's such an enormous topic
you know I mean of course in a democracy
to some extent has to be populist in
many ways but you see populism is an
emphasis of evolution we see almost
unilateral emphasis on majority
sentiment majority opinion majority
preferences where the rights of
minorities and the rights of opposition
are under emphasized and not even
sometimes even not properly upheld and
observed but this is a complicated thing
you know this the dis disclosed there's
something beneath this that is more
important than the emphasis of
majorities as against the right of
minorities this is what I mentioned only
in passing the tremendous influence of
publicity you see through publicity
popularity can be manufactured
constructed sometimes even falsely
established repeated and repeated you
see by repeating and repeating and
repeating that something is popular at
least temporarily
it becomes popular and this this is
where you know the our elections are no
longer merely popularity contests they
are publicity contests publicity can be
and and you see this is very interesting
consequences one consequence of this is
that is not really majoritarianism
because we have now know the whole world
has always had but we perhaps especially
have now a phenomenon that cannot be
expressed statistic
we have hard minorities and soft
majorities you say hard minority at
least for a while can have an influence
which goes way beyond its actual power
and numbers this will not last forever
as I told you people must not be
regarded as incurable you know but it
can happen
well III don't really deal with this not
just because of kind of modesty okay but
all I do is read the newspaper one
newspaper and even at newspaper I read
with less and less enthusiasm in new
york times think it's getting worse and
worse but so also i can i want to tell
you that in a way of course you see the
mistakes made in this war are now so
great that it proves burke that people
cannot be regards incurable but you must
understand it three years three years
ago this war was immensely popular you
know for no matter what reasons people
were not interested whether the whether
the iraqis have weapons of mass
destruction or not this war was very
popular and our politicians and i
believe that this is no longer so but
again you see if i i am convinced that
if in nineteen oh in in 2003 or two sent
to the president's advisers would have
thought that this war will be very
unpopular they would not have changed
this course they might I probably would
have rightly being involved in
Afghanistan but probably not in Iraq but
this is nothing else but a hypothesis on
my part